In Beijing, China, visiting US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and his Chinese counterpart...
...discussed bilateral relations and the North Korea nuclear issue...
...amid tensions over trade and China's territorial claims in the South China Sea.
In Turkey, on a visit to Budapest,...
...Turkish President Recep Tayyip Erdogan asks Saudi officials...
...to prove their claim that missing Saudi journalist and Riyadh critic Jamal Khashoggi...
...left Riyadh's consulate in Istanbul.
In New Brunswick, flames and a column of smoke are seen rising...
...from Canada's largest oil refinery...
...in what the company that owns it calls a "major incident."
In the Mediterranean,...
...French and Italian vessels were racing to contain a spreading oil spill...
...after two cargo ships collided off the island of Corsica on Sunday.
Finally from Sweden, the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences...
...has awarded this year's Nobel Prize for economics...
...to Yale University's William Nordhaus and New York University's Paul Romer.